[Musique]
l'office de l'eau fête ses 20 ans pour
l'occasion les rencontres de l'eau se
déroulent sur trois jours du mercredi 22
au vendredi 24 mars pour parler de l'or
bleu dans les outre-mer
2023 au bout de longs efforts et bien
nous avons une gestion globale de l'eau
qui a du sens nous avons été chiés de
l'eau de Salazie en passant par ma fate
voilà
distribuer sur toute la région Ouest
nous avons réussi à faire
l'interprétation avec le réseau du Sud
du sud de l'île et donc de l'Ouest et
aujourd'hui on se projette sur la partie
Est de l'île cette eau qui a été captée
elle sert bien sûr
au besoin de la population réunionnaise
et cela est très important mais elle
sert aussi aux besoins de nos
agriculteurs elle est utile au
développement économique touristique
industriel de Lille et donc bravo Puerto
trik a été réalisé il nous reste encore
la partie des hauts et la partie de
l'Est de l'île pour
achever je dirais le grand chantier de
l'eau des rencontres qui inaugurent le
nouveau siège de l'office de l'eau à
Saint-Paul un établissement exemplaire
alors on est parti
sur le fait que l'eau c'est la vie et on
a voulu valoriser cette eau pour le
vivant pour la biodiversité et donc par
rapport à ça on a réalisé quelque chose
d'exemplaire qu'il a une gestion des
eaux pluviales intégrée on va dire avec
la création de nous c'est à dire de
fausser végétalisé qui permet de
récupérer l'eau et qui permettent aussi
de d'alimenter en eau les 2000 plans qui
sont installés sur ce site et ce qui
au-delà du côté agréable participe aussi
à la vie
pour parler de la question de l'eau et
ses enjeux des délégations venus de la
zone mais aussi des territoires
d'outre-mer ainsi que toutes les
institutions et partenaires étaient
présents pour différentes tables rondes
autour de la problématique de l'eau nous
voulons échanger les savoirs nous
voulons partager des connaissances nous
avons des invités de toute l'océan
Indien qui sont présentes mais aussi du
territoire national et il est essentiel
dans ses rencontres sur le sur l'eau de
d'échanger les connaissances et de
partager donc
l'ensemble de nos savoirs pour avancer
encore plus et plus rapidement
l'office de l'eau est un établissement
public local à caractère administratif
rattaché au département son programme
prévisionnel d'intervention et de plus
de 73 millions d'euros sur la période
2022 2027
[Musique]